it's frightening to think about how many
people go missing each year
approximately sixteen hundred
individuals mysteriously vanish each
year in National Parks alone one moment
they're there making their way down a
hiking trail or stopping for a granola
bar by a lake and the next they're gone
missing people are an unfortunate fact
of life one we all just try to put out
of our minds as we silently hope we and
those we know and love will be fortunate
enough to avoid joining the ranks of the
lost but some places some very strange
obscure places nestled in the quiet
Countryside and tucked away under
blankets of fog lose so many people that
it becomes well anomalous one particular
town a seemingly innocuous place with a
thriving tourism industry was the site
of so many unexplained disappearances
that had drew the attention of the SCP
Foundation they dispatched a team to
enter the
to gather as many facts and figures as
they could and to see what exactly had
become of these missing people leading
the team was none other than the
sometimes Fearless often Shameless Dr
Jack Bright how did the infamous Dr
bright get here well for many employees
of the SCP Foundation leading a task
force to investigate a new potentially
anomalous location would be a promotion
or a welcome diversion from yet another
round of testing to see if maybe
something will finally destroy scp-682
but in this particular case it was a
matter of discipline after Dr bright was
caught giving scp-999 a triple shot of
espresso to quote just see what would
happen he was assigned to fieldwork as
part of his punishment for the record
what happened was scp-999 ricocheting
off the walls at such a high speed and
intensity that it broke several Windows
damaged the ceiling and knocked out the
power for half of the site and so Dr
bright found himself with a task course
of foundation operatives trudging
reluctantly through beautiful but boring
rural New England toured the town of
Interest as he drove down the winding
road grumbling to himself and wishing he
could be anywhere else he spotted the
sign marking their intended destination
welcome to Silent Hill up ahead of thick
fog rolling off the lake covered the
town in the dim gray blur he couldn't
make out anything through the
unnaturally dense Haze he squinted and
turned on the high beams but the light
did nothing to cut through the fog
bouncing off of it like a billowing
curtain of white just as they passed the
sign the van began to slow rapidly its
engines sputtering and grinding as the
vehicle skidded to a sudden stop damn it
Dr bright thumped the steering wheel in
frustration any of you know how to fix a
car he looked at the team of operatives
in the back seat they all Shrugged
non-committally the only thing worse
than wandering into that fog would be
sitting in the broken down van watching
Tweedledum and tweedled summer tried to
attend to the failing engine his private
joke almost lifted his mood but not
quite he popped open the door and
stepped out into the cold damp air well
I'll figure it out I'm gonna go look
around Dr bright shoved his hands into
his pockets and not knowing what might
wait on the other side began his walk
into silent hill with each step he
ruminated on the events that had gotten
him here where did those guys at the
foundation get off disciplining him like
an unruly child sure he liked his pranks
he enjoyed a good joke and maybe
sometimes he took it just a little bit
too far but he'd like to see them
confront the existential dread of
immortality without needing a humorous
Outlet every now and then they'd crack
under the pressure without a release of
some kind so what gave them the right to
put him a brilliant if unconventional
mind in some kind of glorified time out
he scoffed out loud to himself and the
sound echoed in the vacant streets the
sheer emptiness of it all snapped him
out of self-pity and for the first time
he looked up to take in his surroundings
the stubborn fog refused to dissipate no
matter how far he walked but at least he
could make out the shape of the
buildings now of parked cars on the side
of the road no not parked wrecked
abandoned left to rust he scanned the
fog for human Silhouettes listen for
voices for any signs of life but there
was no one he approached a building and
found it dilapidated rotted wood
collapsing in on itself windows cracked
door boarded up tight the buildings next
to it looked very much the same what the
hell it was sent to investigate recent
disappearances but this town looked as
if its entire population had vanished
decades ago or he thought with a small
shutter all decided to leave in a hurry
one could have driven them out okay
that's it I'm done Dr bright remark
turning a swift 180 degrees and
preparing to go back the way he came as
he did froze where there had once been
continuous unbroken Road the street now
ended in a jagged edge a deep dark Chasm
the only thing that waited Beyond it was
too broad to jump across and he couldn't
see another road out of town hey guys he
called out hoping to draw the attention
of one of the men he had left with the
van a little help over here but
hello he shouted again louder this time
when no one answered he repeated himself
again and again with increasing
desperation his voice growing hoarse
from the effort had they somehow fixed
the van and left him there had they
fallen into the chasm where the road
once was and been killed on impact there
was no rational explanation for what was
at play here but as the consciousness of
a man living inside of an ancient amulet
reminded himself he rarely rarely
encountered rational things in his life
there had to be a way out he just had to
find it if he can go back well he would
just have to keep moving forward on
through the winding Labyrinth of the
street through the Maze of crumbling
buildings looking for any signs of life
he followed a natural Bend in the road
and suddenly found himself wedged
between two buildings done a narrow
claustrophobic alley it seemed that this
place didn't feel much like playing by
the ordinary rules of time and space and
while Dr bright could usually appreciate
a rule breaker being a little rebellious
himself elf that uncertainty was putting
him on edge his breaths came in Shallow
gasps his chest typed with apprehension
as he turned in a circle looking for the
best way out he heard a sound behind him
the first noise he had heard other than
his own breathing in quite some time it
was the soft plotting sound of uneven
footsteps like someone small walking
with a limp he Whirled around to face
the noise and saw what he might have
mistaken for a child until he got a
proper look at it the thing that was
steadily approaching him was small and
humanoid in shape but that was where the
similarities to a human being ended its
skin was a pale modeled gray the shade
of a body fished out of a river after
weeks of bloating and Decay its mouth
was a twisted gaping hole more like a
wound than a mouth and in place of its
eyes were a pair of slits in the pale
flesh it stumbled as it walked like it
was still learning how but the childish
ineptitude did nothing to distract from
the creatures Menace as it Advanced
towards Dr Wright he saw the glint of
something metal and the creature's
gnarled fist it held a rusty knife as it
got closer it slashed haphazardly in his
Direction and its mouth opened wider to
let out a chilling high-pitched giggle
this thing was preparing to carve him up
and enjoy every second of the job as he
took in the sight of the horrible gray
child in front of him Dr bright had been
frozen to the spot unable to force his
legs to carry him away but the sight of
the knife the Grim realization of just
exactly what this thing had in store for
him shocked him back to life he grabbed
a wooden beam leading up against the
nearest wall and threw it at the little
monster knocking it onto its back it was
immobilized just long enough for Dr
bright to get his bearings turn and run
toward the wider Street as he did he
could hear the gleeful laughter as the
creature climbed back to its feet and it
only pushed him to run faster when he
could no longer hear the Little
Footsteps or the Warped Giggles of the
great child Dr bright stopped to catch
his breath so it seemed like there was
still life in Silent Hill after all
there just wasn't human life there was
silence for a moment nothing but Dr
Wright's heart pounding in his head as
he bent over his knees and silently
cursed himself for not exercising this
body more often then the shrill Cry of
an air raid siren ripped through the
foggy air and for a moment his heart
stopped what the hell did that sound
mean he stood up inspecting his
surroundings for signs of danger for
what a tornado a bomb he wasn't sure but
nothing could have prepared him for what
he saw next the entire landscape had
shifted around him in an instant he was
unsure of how exactly to describe it
except to say that this world had gotten
darker more dangerous where the streets
had been lit by dim gray sunlight
filtered through the haze there was now
Darkness save for an occasional Street
Lamp with a flickering red bulb he
couldn't be sure if it was a trick of
the light but he could swear there was
blood staining the street smeared across
the brick walls of buildings on either
side the town had been ominous before
but now it was like something out of a
nightmare and all the while the siren
continued to blare warning of a danger
he could not see he needed to find
shelter that was it from what he didn't
know but whatever was coming could not
be good Dr bright ran to the nearest
door twisting the knob trying to yank it
open but it wouldn't budge the hinges
were rusted shut and there was no time
to try and force them open he tried
another door and another and another it
was as if the house is new to try and
keep him out to keep him exposed and
vulnerable on the outside finally he
reached a two-story house with peeling
white paint and a mahogany door one that
looked so familiar with that he couldn't
quite place when he turned the knob the
door creaked open with ease and he
quickly raced inside slamming the door
shut behind him and locked it as Dr
Wright slumped against the door
overtaken with exhaustion an intrusive
thought made his stomach drop was he
alone in this house had he really found
shelter or had he just shut himself
inside with something even worse than
what waited out there in the silence he
could swear he heard the quiet thumping
of a pulse but he couldn't tell if it
was his own or the houses beating heart
he couldn't just stay here dreaming up
all the horrors that might be waiting he
needed to gather data investigate his
surroundings and come up with potential
Solutions he needed to be a scientist on
unsteady legs Dr bright began to walk
the halls of the house taking in his
surroundings properly for the first time
it was Dusty and dark a place left
vacant for quite some time but there
were signs of a life once lived within
the House's walls a rocking horse in the
corner a Shelf full of well-worn books
the titles scratched and itch in his
brain memories he hadn't touched in
decades strange that so many of the
books in this house would remind him of
the pages he once flipped through
staying inside to read while his brother
played in the yard outside his brother
Dr bright swallowed the lump in his
throat at the thought of TJ no use going
down that path not right now he
continued his walk through the house
taking in the cobwebs the couch covered
with plastic the coffee table and the TV
set along the hall leading to the
bathroom there were rows of family
pictures hanging in neat little frames
he stopped to take a look wondering what
sort of family had once lived here as
his eyes fell on the first photograph
his blood turned to ice in his veins a
boy looked out from within the frame a
familiar boy with a mop of red hair a
freckled nose and kind smiling eyes now
Dr bright whispered to himself but there
was no denying it it was TJ his brother
somehow looking at him from inside a
photograph in an abandoned house in
Silent Hill next there was a photo of TJ
and an older man Dr Bright's stomach
turned their father every photograph was
of his family the family he would never
know again not the way they were and
there in one photo in the middle TJ and
his father were joined by another figure
one with the face scratched out of the
picture he knew though he couldn't see
for certain that it was him removed from
the family photo by force but the bond
between them all forever broken TJ's
eyes and the picture seemed to be filled
with tears heartbroken his father
glowered out of the frame at an pure
hatred in his gaze he couldn't look any
more and turned away on the opposite
wall another photograph of TJ was
waiting Dr bright fell bile Rising his
throat he recognized the photo he saw it
sometimes when he closed his eyes at
night was a picture taken with scp-978
the desired camera the anomalous camera
that reveals its subject's innermost
desires in the photo TJ's hands were
pressed to the lens like an animal
clawing at the boundaries of its cage
his eyes were filled with tears spilling
over and streaming down his cheeks and
his mouth was wide open in an endless
scream of fear and agony this Dr bright
knew was the worthless scream inside his
brother's mind at all times after so
much testing with the foundation had
destroyed him
tried to help you he whispered to the
picture I did what I could do I did what
I could to take the pain away he trailed
off the words dying in his throat as the
sound of a heavy rattling breath came
from the room at the end of the hall it
was a thick wheezing sound like a death
rattle a dozen times over he didn't want
to see what was making the noise but as
if in a trance he found his feet
carrying him towards it he crossed the
threshold of what should have been in
the kitchen but instead found himself in
the dimly lit Hospital the air smell the
formaldehyde and dried vomit the steady
beep of a heart monitor joining the
chorus of heavy agonizing breathing at
the end of the Long Haul there was one
single room the door standing slightly
ajar with slow agonizing steps Dr bright
approached the room the breathing grew
louder and louder the beef of the heart
monitor almost deafening in his ears he
could barely separate the strange
breathing from his own finding his
breaths coming in time with the painful
rattling sound he pushed the door open
and saw a figure lying in a hospital bed
it was once human but it could only be
described now as a conglomerate of
disease and pain
on top of the figure's head thinning in
patches but still recognizable was a log
of red hair no
TJ no Dr Bright's voice broke off in a
sob at the sight the thing that was once
his brother turned seeking the sound of
his voice though he could not see isn't
this what you wanted a low voice rumbled
behind him Dr bright Whirled around to
see a dark shadow red eyes glowing in
the low light it moved like a wisp of
black smoke but he knew that voice well
enough to tell him just who it was his
father you let them do this to him
I didn't I didn't mean for this to
happen Dr bright Stamford you didn't
care the demon father roared and the
light bulb above their heads flared and
burst sending shards of glass scattering
everywhere all he ever did was help
people to heal pain and all you ever did
was cause it Dr bright found the
strength to move running through the
doorway sending the shape of his father
in every direction as the smell of
sulfur and blood filled his nose I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry he wept as he
ran hearing his father's agonized cries
his brothers labored breathing as he
tore back down the hospital Hall as he
did hands began to reach through the
walls the floor of the ceiling they were
Rotting Flesh gone green and stiff arms
followed the hands then shoulders then
faces he recognized d-class uniforms lab
coats face after familiar face everyone
who had ever worn The Amulet he realized
with a sudden wave of nausea everyone
who's by body he had taken who he had
killed so that he could live this is
what you do he could hear his father's
voice just behind him the curls of black
smoke nipping at his heels what kind of
creature kills to live something that
deserves to die but you can't can you
you're a parasite sucking all the good
in the life from this world until it's
an empty husk just like you the living
graveyard of victims reach for Dr bright
tearing at his clothes as he passed them
there were so many he never realized how
many until he saw them all lined up like
this I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry he
said to every face he passed but there
was no forgiveness in their dead eyes
his father's voice fell silent but there
was no reprieve instead there was the
sound of heavy footsteps pursuing him
degrading shriek of a large bladed
weapon dragging along the ground Dr
bright glanced over his shoulder and saw
a massive hulking figure like a man but
with a jagged metal pyramid covering his
head he was clad in blood-stained
clothing and approaching Dr Bryant with
the Casual Menace of something that had
killed endless times before and was
ready to do it again it didn't care to
chase him it knew it would eventually
catch up as he looked at the figure it
began to warp to to change it morphed
into something else something he
recognized a man with black hair and
gray eyes that revealed nothing but cold
malice a body covered in tattoos of the
Arcane and the Occult of merciless
grinning faces belonging to ancient
monsters and in his hand a long-bladed
weapon a curved soared perfectly
engineered for battle it was impossible
he should be contained but there he was
scp-076-2 looking at Dr bright the same
way he had on the day he had first worn
The Amulet the day he became an
Abomination the sound of his brother's
breathing grew louder his father's voice
bellowing in his mind and he felt the
grasp of the Fallen Foundation employees
at his back it was all too much too many
reminders of every failure every hurt Dr
bride collapsed to his knees and bared
his neck to Abel in submission you're
right I I should be punished I've done
nothing but hurt and kill and destroy
everything I touch just punish me please
I'm begging you then something Dr bright
never could have expected the figure
that looked like Abel but couldn't be
began to laugh a cruel Hollow sound
no it said in a voice that sounded like
a chorus of hundreds we will release you
nothing we can do here will ever be
worse than the eternity of Torment that
stretches before you good luck to you Dr
bright Jack Bright let out a whale of
Agony reaching out to Abel with pleading
hands as the entity turned and slowly
walked away leaving him there alone with
the hell that was his thoughts then
everything faded to Black Dr bright Dr
bright the sound of one of his team
members brought Dr Wright back to
Consciousness and he opened his eyes he
was lying on the side of the same road
he had walked along before right next to
the sign welcoming the group to Silent
Hill we're all still here he asked
weekly what do you mean the man looked
puzzled he parked the van you got out
you fell down and we've been trying to
wake you up how long was I out Dr
Bright's Vision swim as he tried to wrap
his mind around the information I don't
know about 10 minutes now go check out
what if you were related to Dr bright
scp-590 he feels your pain and SCP
Edition weirdest things on Amazon Dr
Bright's great idea for more funny and
tragic Tales from the book of Dr bright